Um, I just wanted to uh talk about how
we in the Old Testament um
when we look at Genesis and I I actually
might have asked you this in the chat
when you did the live stream about
creationalism and all that stuff.
>> Creationalism.
>> Yeah. So, I have a hard time believing
um I can accept the part about Adam
being the first man,
>> but I have a hard time with the um the
thing about the 5,000 years like uh like
the human race being 5,000 years old and
God creating in six days. So,
>> time were you there at the beginning to
see it?
>> Oh, I wasn't there. Um, but um I'm I'm
just saying like scientifically,
>> how do you know that the scientifically
statements that you're appealing to are
actually based on facts, not on
interpretation of the data?
>> Were you there in the beginning to see
it?
>> Uh, no. But science is the
interpretation of data, right?
>> Which science? Because I gave you a
group of scientists that say that's not
what the data says. That's a
manipulation of the data. So, which
science?
>> Um,
like probably astrophysics. Like,
>> you mean if I bring you Jason Lyle, an
astrophysicist who believes in young
earth creationism, and he's going to say
you're a liar?
>> I I think it's more of a thing like the
majority opinion. And the majority
opinion is regarding
>> You're saying truth is determined by a
majority vote. Then if that's the case,
the majority of people identify as
Christians. There's over two billion and
the largest church denomination is the
Catholic Church. So aren't you Catholic?
>> I mean, yeah, that's a good question.
>> Yeah, because brother, you don't listen
and you're kind of slow, but I love you.
So again, how do you know how old the
earth is? Were you there to witness God
creating it?
>> No, I I No, I was. So you're appealing
to a select branch of science that
starts as part of its fundamental
presupposition
that the Bible is not true. It's not
historically accurate and then will
interpret the data in such a way to then
confirm their hypothesis because no one
was there from the beginning. It's all
observation. But even their observation
will be based on certain assumptions
such as carbon dating and its validity
or the rate in which light travels.
These are all assumptions that are being
challenged by another group of
scientists using the same facts to show
you're wrong. Our model best explains
the data.
>> Okay. Yeah, I guess that makes sense.
But is does does it really matter to my
like salvation or anything whether I
believe in it fully or not or
>> Well, it matters in that it will get you
to lose confidence in the Bible because
then you're going to have to water down
the Bible, explain it away in order to
then make it agree with science. So why
is it the tendency of Christians is to
dilute the Bible, water down the Bible,
reinterpret the Bible in order to make
it agree with scientific views that
change and vary
because then that means the standard is
not God's word but science. So now
you're placing science above God's word,
which means the Bible has to always bow
down and be subject to science. Well,
what if a 100 years from now they change
their views radically? Are you now going
to reinterpret the Bible once again to
make it agree with these evolving views
of science? Pun intended.
>> Uh, no, I would not.
>> No, but that's what you're doing.
Because today the view is that the earth
is 5 billion years old, right? And it
evolved. But over 100 years ago, that
wasn't the view. In fact, the view was
that the earth, the universe did not
have a beginning.
>> Yeah.
So now
>> if you were living over 100 years ago
then you would have to argue in a
different manner in a different way to
try to argue for the origin of the
universe. But now because macro
evolution has become a dominant view.
We now have to argue in a different
manner, different way to show that
either the Bible agrees with it and
therefore butcher the Bible or we're
going to have to now present arguments
that macro evolution is not true because
maybe 100 years from now they're going
to abandon macro evolution for a
completely different theory altogether.
>> Mhm.
>> So why would I want to stake my
understanding of the Bible on evolving
pun intended scientific theories?
Uh I think my point of view sort of
comes from I was watching the uh Coptic
Orthodox Answers explanation of Genesis
and uh
>> brother how modern Coptic priests with
good intentions or Catholic priests or
Eastern Orthodox priests seek to
interpret Genesis in order to make the
faith sensible to Christians who are
being poisoned by theories
shoved down their throat. by
naturalistic materialists, a theory that
was actually established to challenge
biblical origins. They mean well, but
they're wrong. Because if I ask the
Coptic Orthodox priests or the Catholic
priests or the Eastern Orthodox priests,
what has been the unanimous teaching of
all the saints of the church up until
the rise of macro evolution? How did
they interpret Genesis 1-11?
So they all got it wrong until science
evolved and therefore now we have to
discard what these Christians thought
about Genesis 1:11 as being sacred
history, not just myth history or
mythology.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. I understand there are Coptic
priests and there are Catholic priests
and not only that but Catholic
apologists and Protestant event with
good intentions trying to water down
Genesis and reinterpret Genesis to make
it sensible to the world that hates God.
So then when do you stop the compromise?
How much compromise
in order to appease the world and when
does it stop? Because do you think that
even if I acquies
and I agree that Genesis can be
reinterpreted to
make it compatible with macro revolution
that automatically is going to make them
believe in Christ?
>> Yeah. No. How many people who are
naturalistic materialists who believe in
evolution reject God have become
Christian because theistic evolutionist
say you can hold to evolution and
believe in God?
>> Not many.
>> Yeah. But I feel like there are many
Christians who uh sort of theistic
evolution might um help their faith and
keep their faith in.
>> No, it's it's because they don't want to
be laughed at and scoffed at as being
pseudointellectuals. In other words,
their shame of being laughed at and not
respected by the world is causing them
to butcher scripture to appease the
world, but in so doing angering God.
Do you think we would have theistic
evolutionists if macroevolution wasn't
the dominant view? Where are your
theistic evolutionists prior to Darwin?
Well, yeah, there was no concept of
evolution. So, they wouldn't have
>> So, then why do you think theistic
evolution exists
>> uh to respond to uh natural
selectionists and
>> Yeah. But it's that's not a response.
That's a concession and admittance of
defeat.
>> Okay. Yeah.
>> Right.
>> Yeah.
>> How's that a response? Notice yourself.
I want you to hear yourself. I want you
to hear yourself. You just admitted when
there was no macroevolution, there were
no theistic evolutionists.
So the fact that now we had to adopt a
theory and try to Christianize it and
it's not just Christians. You have Jews
and Muslims doing it, that means we've
now caved in, give in, conceded to the
world because we want the love and
respect of the world.
>> Mhm.
So what if a 100 years from now they
abandon completely the enterprise of
macro evolution? Are we again going to
reinterpret the Bible in order to
concede and cave in and appease them?
>> No, probably not. We shouldn't. So
>> but that's the pattern with the church
so far, right? That's what they're
doing.
>> Yeah. I mean many churches do. Yeah.
>> So this is why I respect the
creationists because they're being
faithful to the plain reading of
scripture. Unless you have good
contextual reasons to allegorize it.
Obviously Jesus missed the memo. Paul
missed the memo. The early Christians
missed the memo. Even the Jews missed
the memo until the rise of macro
revolution. That Genesis 1-11 is not
meant to be taken as sacred history.
They all took it as history.
You may have some people here and there
saying, "Well, the days can be
interpreted to be a thousand years
because a day is a thousand years of the
Lord. But even then, you don't get
billions of years. You still get several
thousands of years."
>> Mhm. Yeah.
>> And what does the Bible say? Warns you
about doing here. Let's let me show you.
All right. Here. So, I
used to believe in old earth because
it's still affirmed Genesis 1. But the
more I thought about it, the more I
studied, no, I can't go that route
because of Genesis chapter 9 says there
was no flesh eating prior to the flood.
Well, you can't have animals dying and
praying on one another right before Adam
showed up on the scene because that
didn't happen until after the flood. So
anyway, here here's what the Bible says
about you trying to appease the world.
James 4:4.
James 4:4. You adulteresses, do you not
know that friendship with the world is
enmity toward God? Therefore, whoever
wishes to be a friend of the world sets
himself as an enemy of God. All right,
that's number one. Don't think that
trying to befriend the world is going to
make God happy because the world hates
God and it hates you because you love
God. And the more you compromise to
appease the world, you end up with
female clergy who are lesbian.
>> Yeah,
>> right.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, how'd that happen, man?
Because we want the praise of the world.
Oh, no. You know, the Bible doesn't say
that bishops can only be men. That's a
misreading of the Bible. And yet they
can't point to you anywhere in church
history where there were female bishops.
I'm not saying deacons. This is where
they try to catch you,
right? Oh, no. You know, when it talks
about homosexuality, it's a particular
context and it has to do not so much
with healthy monogous homosexual
Christians. It has to do with paganism
and idolatry and other perversions. But
if you do it in the confine of just
monogamous love between people, that's
okay. Come on, man.
>> Yeah. My sister my sister recently
actually sent me a video of like this
pastor talking about how the Bible isn't
inherent and how um it has mistakes.
>> Did you catch it? Now the Bible is not
inherent. Why? Because an inherent Bible
means you cannot justify these
perversions,
these abominations, these views. So what
do you do? Attack the credit of the
Bible. So you lose faith in the Bible
and then go with the world's agenda. But
did you know that's what Satan did? What
was Satan's first attack besides attack
on the family to get you to doubt God's
word whether you can trust it? Did he
not say to Eve? Did God really say the
first attack to destroy a person's faith
is to get you to doubt these are God's
words or God really said it?
>> Yeah.
>> Right.
All right. But now watch here. Here's
what our Lord says.
If the world hates you, John 15:18-19,
know that it has hated me before it
hated you. If you were of the world, the
world will love its own. But because you
are not of the world, but I chose you
out of the world, because of this, the
world hates you. So how can you have the
world loving you if you love Jesus?
If the world loves you, there's
something wrong with that picture, you
adulterous, is James 4:4. Do you not
know that friendship with the world is
enemy toward God? Therefore, whoever
worship to be a friend of the world sets
himself as an enemy of God. And that's
why Paul warned you nearly 2,000 years
ago. See to it that no one takes you
captive through philosophy and empty
deception according to the tradition of
men. And by the way, philosophy is the
love of wisdom. Science would also be a
branch of philosophy, so to speak,
right?
>> According to the elementary principles
of the world, not according to Christ.
For in him all the fullness of deity
dwells bodily. And in him you have been
filled who's head of over all rule and
authority. Now let me show you that even
science falls under the rubric of
philosophy because philosophy means fo
sophia love of wisdom
and even the word science simply means
to be sentient you know see it wisdom
wise.
Yeah.
>> Pray for me, brother. If you're go
there, lift me up in prayer. Let the
saints, the monks, pray for me and my
family. Purity, holiness to love Jesus,
and health and protection. Please pray.
Have them pray for my family. Now Paul
already warned you people come using
philosophy
based on human wisdom and understanding
which is influenced inspired by the
elementary principle meanings the wicked
demonic forces that permeate the world
in order to lead you astray because that
wisdom that philosophy is not based on
the revelation of Jesus Christ. It
contradicts it.
>> You get it? Yeah.
>> So, either we're going to stick to
scripture and then use the Bible as the
lens to interpret scientific facts and
once we do, it all fits in perfectly.
Scientific facts don't contradict the
Bible properly interpret it. Or we're
going to allow them to interpret facts
and spin a narrative in a fairy tale of
origins
which contradict the Bible and out of
fear of backlash and being looked down
as idiots, we then water down the Bible,
pervert the Bible to get their respect.
Why do I want their respect, man? What
are they going to do for me when I die?
>> Yeah, you're right. Anyway, Sam, I have
to My parents are home, so I have to
head out.
>> You tell your parents that if I find
them, I'll bless them. No, just kidding.
Take care.
>> Um, and also please like I just want to
say like to you Sam and everybody in the
chat like please pray for me because
>> we will.
>> Just the the road ahead just feels like
really long. So
>> All right. That's all right. Well, here
take my email if you ever want to go
live with me at a time when your parents
are not there. Let me know. Here it is.
Contact me. All right.
>> Okay. Thank you. Thank you.
>> All right. So say I send in private
chat. Okay.
>> All right. So there you go guys.